moi faire car d'été une hyper view bah
oui barret c'est vrai que ça vous tombe
dessus un moment avec chez moi à faire
une hyper view que ça va donner vous
donner en plus l'occasion de répondre à
un certain nombre de papiers que j'ai vu
sur vous dernièrement et qui étaient pas
tous très sympathiques en tous les cas
donc vous pouvez poser des questions
aussi à pierre arditi peut-être pas sur
les mêmes que moi mais sont-ils un sujet
plus progressive la question plus
intéressante qu'elle est plus
intéressante que moi ça sera difficile
alors il y avait un article dans libé
c'était lundi dernier le riz aux qui
disait pierre arditi talent caché caché
chu teh il parlait de vous en disant
vous faites partie des acteurs qui
pompent les gros le gros des cachets de
la fiction à la télé et il parlait de
stars vieillissantes
oui bon parce que comme on a presque le
même âge je trouve ça ignoble je tiens à
le dire
d'abord il faudrait vous devrez
expliquer à la personne qui a écrit cela
dont je ne sais pas le nom puisque c'est
maintenant c'est juste des initiatives
et que par initiatrice tard c'est
exagéré oui vous dois mourir parce que
c'est très exactement ce que veulent
dire les web
sega vous d'abord faudrait déjà cessé
d'employer ce mot à tord et à travers
parce qu'ils ne signifient plus rien une
star c'est quelque chose de très
particulier il y en a extrêmement peu je
n'en fais pas partie
alors c'est pas du tout la fausse
modestie chez moi je ne suis absolument
pas une star ensuite bon je ne vois pas
trop l'intérêt de 2,2 me regarder de
cette manière là d'abord bien évidemment
je ne pompe pas à moi tout seul
l'ensemble de l'argent de la fiction on
voit que sur certains certaines chaînes
ils en font tellement peu qu'après tout
on peut penser que jean pons qu'une
bonne partie cette sortie de pas citer
de noms voilà non mais
je veux dire par là que je n'ai rien à
dire sur le fait qu'on puisse critiquer
en l'occurrence une série de télévision
qui s'appellerait un font six que j'ai
tourné que brigitte fossey vallègue du
prr certain nombre d'autres jeux qu'on
vend très bien vous même pas ça on a
tout à fait le droit de le dire ça me
choque absolument pas je n'ai rien à
dire là dessus je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de me -2 2 me taper la gueule de cette
manière là d'abord parce que tout ça est
évidemment totalement faux je ne
fonctionne pas plus qu'un certain nombre
d'autres gens qui travaillent dans les
finances et même chaîne
ensuite mon dieu je suis j'ai toujours
dit je crois que je monte je suis un
acteur pluridisciplinaire ça que je fais
du théâtre du cinéma de la télévision
quelquefois même jeudi les textes que je
mon honneur à moi c'est de passer
d'alain resnais a fait 2 ou de beckett à
guitry que je considère que mon métier
c'est ça que j'ai été baigné dans ce
bain là puisque nous avons à peu près le
même âge et que nous avons été biberonné
à rob est riche c'est habib rené robert
hirsch
j'ai été biberonné à jouer j'ai été
biberonné à brasseur je ne me compare
pas à eux mais autant que je m'en
souvienne ces gens là faisait aussi un
peu ça c'est à dire que brasseur disait
lui-même
je vais m'amuser dans la journée je vais
faire mon métier le serveur tout à fait
bon donc je vois pas en quoi cette chose
sera une tare ensuite que soit
vieillissant naturellement je suis
vieillissant je trouve que finalement je
vis ni plutôt pas trop mal
le tout est plutôt mieux merci à 25 est
ce que est ce que vous pensez que car
d'itv bien franchement oui je trouve
comme un homme est plus beau quand je
suis en mai le film c'est le montrent
les femmes mais beaucoup plus beaucoup
continuer parce qu'il devient plus
mature et voilà c'est vrai je sais pas
il sait pas mais voilà tout ça tout ça
simplement pour dire tout ça pour dire
eh bien cette grotte
tout ça tout ça pour dire que ça m'a
profondément déplu non pas qu'on n'aime
pas cette série ça je manque enfin tape
complètement mais que cette manière de
me regarder
je la trouve infâme et finalement comme
dirait l'autre il ya des lettres qui
vaut mieux recevoir plutôt de les avoir
écrites la déshonore leurs auteurs à 16
minutes ça vous emmerde rey - oui je
relèverai mais bien sûr vous avez raison
ça me ça me blesse parce qu'une certaine
manière c'est un journal que j'aime bien
et c'est un journal que je lis
pratiquement tous les jours mais ma
lecture de libération s'arrête aux pages
politiques économiques
là je ne lis plus les pages culturelles
de libération qui sont j'ai le regret de
le dire des pages totalement incomplète
pour le moins qui en ce sens toute
petite partie de ce qui se passe
culturellement dans notre pays
en conséquence de quoi je trouve que les
pages de cultura de libération ne font
pas leur boulot
non pas parce qu'elle ne m'attaque mois
mais encore une fois ça me blesse
puisque j'aime bien ce journal je veux
dire que cette manière de regarder me
fait un peu penser à une presse
d'occupation qui tout d'un coup
deviendrait racisme alors je n'ai pas
envie qu'on vienne racistes avec moi je
crois n'avoir rien fait dans ma vie qui
mérite ce traitement la très bien non
mais ce qu'on pourrait se dire est ce
que le fait d vous avez 50 3 ans donc
est ce que le fait 54 est ce que subit
jeunes que vous alors est ce que ces
questions avant de passer à rêver
peut-être vous préparé une série pour
france 2 qui s'appelle les 80 unarc et
donc qu'ils parlent des gens de gauche
qui ont perdu leur âme après 80 parle
d'une de tout de tout un groupe de gens
qui traversent cette période au moment
où la gauche arrive au pouvoir qui ne
sont pas forcément de gauche d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas le sentiment d'avoir
perdu votre âme vous non je n'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir perdu mon âme et je
n'ai pas l'impression que tous les gens
de gauche est forcément perdu leur âme
même si à certains moments ils se sont
un peu perdus
très bien alors on en arrive à rêver
peut-être donc est la pièce que de jean
claude grumberg que vous jouez au
théâtre du rond point des champs elysées
avec michel aumont marcel maréchal et
chantal neuwirth mise en scène de jean
michel ribes or ce que je veux dire
parce que là suis pas critique de cinéma
eric et non plus au québec de théâtre et
les pieds non plus vrai c'est vrai qu'on
est allé voir cette pièce est que les
lieux main dans la main dans la main
puisque maintenant comme vous le savez
un ensemble on attaque cédant que non
mais sérieusement on sait je veux dire
c'est une pièce grave
mais le texte est tellement drôlement
écrit avec certaines fois d'ailleurs
grunberg loaded
à côté un peu al mana vermont un essai
tellement mis en scène une façon joyeuse
par ribes que finalement un thème aussi
grave
quelqu'un qui veut venger son père dont
le père a disparu pendant la guerre qui
veulent venger enfin j'en parle mal
parce que dit nous c'est un rêve en fait
ce qui est formidable c'est que c'est
comme un c'est comme un rêve comme un
rêve oui mais c'est au fond la pièce
elles disent que ce que grumberg a assez
souvent dit il est obsédé par l'image de
ce père déporté qui ne connaît pas et au
fond à l'intérieur de ce dans l'atelier
le levant et thématique est très
classique avait très terrienne on attend
quelqu'un doit revenir là revenir ici on
voit apparaître une sorte de spectre qui
est un spectacle qui est à la fois le
spectre d'avnet mais qui est aussi le
spectre de ce père perdu simplement les
dans le domaine du rêve et on est dans
le domaine de la nuit et là le combat de
la nuit l'a emporté sur le combat du
jour et la nuit
tout est possible tout est permis mais
plus rien ne sera un penny oui et c'est
ça en fait la thématique de la pièce ça
me au milieu d'un magma qu'est celui
d'un rêve globale qui comme dans tous
les rêves semblent n'avoir ni queue ni
tête et quand même petit tableau qui
bien entendu ça prend une cohérent si
bien on ira par par emmené par en escroc
mais en réalité d'ailleurs cet enfant
homme vers sa douleur initial qui est
celle de la perte de ce personnes
enfants se sont vus par chantal neuwirth
au début c'est ça c'est son épouse après
c'est sa mère dans sa femme ses traits
on dirait je sais pas si c'est une bonne
façon d'envoyer les gens voir la pièce
mais ça fait penser à un bon trip
d'acide quoi c'est bien bien briller ou
les sens et j'ai tous les baby boomer
comprendront ce que je veux dire
voici pierre arditi
là on bâtit des admis oui j'ai un
dossier sur pierre à la vache bien vous
êtes né à paris le 1er décembre 1944
entraîné pas sa soeur enfin bon je vais
pourquoi tu as un dinosaure thierry sur
ton assez parce que c'est mon fils
gaston il me dit toujours papa dans
l'émission les vachement bien y'a pas de
dinosaures n'ont donc maintenant j'ai un
dinosaure pour gaston voilà tu fais bien
pire et c'est bien que ces missions
n'ont cessé même des dinosaures alors
impunity ça fait une paye qu'on vous a
pas vu c'est quand même temps vous avez
la télé je sais pas ça fait peut-être un
an et demi un an et demi c'est ça vous
avez pas changé c'est toujours aussi
élégant et vous trouvez bah oui
d'ailleurs les prix d'élégance
monsieur longines à une grande soirée au
ritz était deuxième oui ils ont tous
fait 2e d'ailleurs et l'a compris un
truc car dit il on essaie d'y en art 10
ans il a un prix d'élégance facile se
répètent le contraire
non mais c'est le contraire les
prochaines suis plus vieux que lui avait
beaucoup plus longtemps je m'habille
comme ça l'année prochaine je me dirai
en arditi je rentrais élégance pendant
molière et le poids qu'on ça va vous est
pas possible
bah écoutez je n'ai pas dites moi non sa
valorisation bien padres le visage est
bien là non c'est pas mal hein
franchement là c'est bien le maintien à
l'arrêt de bus et je vous regarde m'a
beaucoup servi je regarde très baissier
parce que le problème en fait c'est ça
c'est ça je vois que vous n'avez
absolument rien si si j' avais si je le
mets profil c'est
alors donc c'est en tournée en france
c'est pour ça qu'on voit pas beaucoup à
la télé parce que vous travaillez
vraiment sérieusement va très très
sérieusement depuis combien de temps
vous êtes en tournée avec brio sa le
troisième mois à huy leurs joyeuses
pâques donc bah c'est une pièce de jean
poiret évidemment on va en parler tout
de suite mais d'abord vous savez il ya
un petit rituel dans cette émission
c'est comment on fait voilà les plus
grands acteurs le fond je dis ça pour
arnaud montebourg qui n'a pas voulu le
faire voilà à pierre arditi qu'un grand
comédien français le énorme il le devait
voilà c'est du lourd là quand et comment
il le fait bien
alors c'est à partir du 16 janvier 2001
au théâtre des variétés mises en scène
de votre ami bernard murat avec caroline
silhol et barbara schulz est le signe
d'une comédie de jean poiret je vais
raconter le pitch si vous voulez oui
c'est tout moi ce qui est bien avec moi
fait le pitch yves la différence avec
d'autres animateurs c'est que vous êtes
obligés d'aller vendre votre pièce par
exemple moi je fais tout sauf montebourg
il a été gentil je vais pas vendu son
vieux alors c'est se fixer jouée par
caroline silhol donc qui part pour le
week end de pâques et stéphane c'est
vous son mari en profite pour inviter
une jeune fille qui s'appelle julie qui
joué par barbara schulz mais il ya des
grèves d'avion c'est drôle comme c'est
une vraie comédie à la feydeau à cette
histoire
et alors elle revient elle revient
silhol elle revient et elle trouve son
mari stéphane vous avec la jeune fille
voilà et qu'est ce que vous dites à ce
moment là qu'est ce que vous faites à ce
moment là et bien à ce moment là
j'explique avec un aplomb absolument
colossal que c'est ma fille
voilà d'un premier lit d'un premier
voilà c'est ensuite une fois que le
doigt et mis dans cet engrenage là c'est
à dire dans ce dans ce début de
mensonges
il pousse le mensonge jusqu'à la folie
km h que la folie c'est un petit peu le
mécanisme du tailleur pour dames qui est
aussi l'histoire d'un menteur qui se
fait vous avez joué aussi
oui que j'ai joué seulement il ya 15 ans
spécialisé dans tout ça ça me plaît bien
mais c'est vous sérieusement vous passez
de beckett a fait nous assez facilement
moi je pense que mon métier c'est de
jouer tout se sait pas jouer tout c'est
de jouer les auteurs qui sont dignes de
ce nom espoir est aussi digne d'être
joué que beckett que guitry que fait
donc le grimbert que yasmina reza que
tout le reste c'est malin alors donc ça
commence le 16 janvier au théâtre des
variétés qui appartient à jean paul
belmondo
paul si on regarde jouer le rôle est il
ajouté dans une ambiance et c'est dans
une ancienne ferme et tranquille on
était en paix n'a d'ailleurs film de
belmondo on peut le dire ou c'est tabou
c'est tabou alors c'est un excellent
film pour la télémaintenance et
verrouillé 1
alors vous le principe de votre jeu
d'acteur c'est cette crise est en vous à
travers des expériences personnelles
pour les retranscrire sur scène ou à
l'écran et des fois c'est des choses
très privé dont vous nourrissez vos
personnages vous faites appel à votre
mémoire affective c'est ça c'est votre
façon de métier d'acteur oui pas
seulement enfin vous savez c'est ce
qu'on appelle la méthode stanislavski n
est oui alors je le dis à nos amis des
spectateurs c'est le service public vous
allez voir stanislavski acteur et
metteur en scène russe 1863 1938
animateurs du théâtre d'art de moscou
chez vous un indice est donc là les
metteurs en scène d'antoine tchekhov
entre autres est bon et je ne sais pas
ma méthode à moi c'est que je crois pour
le vivre maintenant depuis 35 ans qu'est
finalement on ne fait que jouer des
petits morceaux de soi même au fur des
personnages qu'on est con naissance et
interprète et au long d'une vie
alors évidemment le but c'est de prendre
à l'intérieur de soi des choses qu'on
peut connaître et de la mettre au
service de quelqu'un qui n'est pas soi
voilà il faut très longtemps pour un
pour le comprendre et deux pour savoir
le faire assez vite si les schèmes pas
comment il fallait quand on joue une
pièce qu'ils ne correspond à rien de ce
qu'on a vécu
y'a rien qui ne correspond pas justement
ça n'existe pas il ya toujours un moment
où allait prendre comme ça ok tiens ça
veut dire que vous ai jamais vécu
comment j'ai fait là parce que la socgen
est arrivé vous de tromper votre femme
pendant ça m'est arrivé en tire
l'arrivée de mme antier mais cette
histoire est une manière de mentir par
exemple kiné qui pourrait par un certain
instant ma véhémence peut me servir de
vérité par exemple comme souvent chez
les gens qui mentent donc je me sers de
cette véhémence dans le mensonge pour
nourrir ce personnage qui lui est
pratiquement à montre acculé être un
menteur professionnel comme ça je peux
le trouver chez moi est ce que on va
passer des choses plus intimes
elle le sait
evelyne bouix que vous avez déjà été
mariée que j'ai déjà été mariée vous
avez un enfant le sexe bbq des bêtes ce
garçon mais qu'il est plus à ses yeux
évidemment sinon le sait maintenant
et ben ça c'est sur wii non parce que
j'essayais de comprendre comment vous
avez pu vous mettre dans la peau de ce
stéphane en fait vous êtes arrivé cette
histoire vous avez un enfant avant votre
mariage il peut revenir alors il m'est
arrivé à une certaine époque d'être
obligé de mentir pour des raisons comme
celle-là oui sans pour autant faire
passer la jeune fille en question pour
ma fille bien sûr alors ni pour ta mère
va sur mer en moi alors une bonne
nouvelle donc d'abord il ya évidemment
les variétés le 16 janvier puis ensuite
le 5 juillet vous fait l'ouverture du
festival d'avignon dans la grande cour
mais fait pas le blasé comme ça ça je
suis assez nom de la déesse et s'amuse à
beaucoup et ouais surtout que c'est
l'école des femmes
oui pied deux moyens bien sûr ils
assurent d'assurer des fois où quoi que
ce soit quand même assez loin ni d'en
faire une émission culturelle donc vous
jouez arnolphe évidemment évidemment
vous avez un succès tardif vous oui hein
vous trouvez par rapport à jordy oui
c'est vrai mais c'est pas mal d'ailleurs
il est temps de vous construire
résultant de vous aimer avant j'ai fait
mon métier je me suis construit je me
suis identifié je pense que la première
premier devoir est le premier travail de
l'acteur c'est d'abord savoir qui il est
rond pouvoir reproduire les autres bon
tout ce temps là m'a servi à ça ça m'a
servi à vivre c'est-à-dire à constituer
un morceau de vie et de ma vie qui me
sert aujourd'hui de matériau de travail
quand je quand je demandais ce que je
viens à peine 20 ans et puis voilà c'est
pas venu c'est pas venu d'un coup
pourtant vous êtes allés au spectacle à
ces jeunes si dans le monde du spectacle
ces jeunes et puisque votre père était
peintre il peut gagner jours il est
toujours et toujours vivant pagesjaunes
dit dans nos îles à 80 6 rebonds le
salut si tu nous regardes arrive à nous
regarde et nous regardent ça lui papa
bon anniversaire voilà
alors vous viviez dans une grande maison
rue des martyrs où il est plein de monde
et c'est lui vous a poussé vers un
métier créatif votre père ça c'est rare
parce que vous dites avec lui était pas
question d'être fonctionnaire ou
ingénieur oui ce qui a était encore plus
rare à l'époque aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu à la mode
tous les tous les gamins ont envie de
devenir chanteur acteur à l'époque
c'était pas très bien vu non plus votre
famille vous étiez vous des cousins avec
les cannetti il ya un prix nobel chez
les cannes est immédiat si seulement les
nobel de littérature en littérature avec
la balle et écrivain mission culturelle
donc je quality oui jacques canetti
qu'avec découvreur de tout le monde
oui qui avait un endroit absolument
formidable qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui
que celle qui s'appelait les trois
baudets l'abonné ou j'ai vu moi débuté
petit garçon moi petit garçon gainsbourg
brel
fernand raynaud raymond devos bon
s'étaient formées j'avais 7 ans b à me
souviens très bien de 7 à 15 jours la
première fois où j'étais à l'époque
quand même temps un vrai choc
1 mais il était jeu il était absolument
magnifique il avait les cheveux tout à
faire à un empattement ton du haras il
avait ses grandes oreilles en chou-fleur
monsieur dray toute ma vie il avait un
magnifique costume prince de galles avec
un col roulé gris perle et des pompes
pointu en v et est d'ores et déjà un
très bon titre et dans des îles étaient
absolument magnifique et chantait génial
et un jour votre père veut dire regarde
ce type il est formidable et c'était
vraiment devos
voilà c'est raymond devos j'ai été
nourri au lait du spectacle vraiment un
baby brauner sa première sortie au
théâtre de pierre arditi à l'âge de 7
ans on comprend tout après comédie
française au poulailler et c'est tout
binger c'est tout neuf ça m'intéresse
il s'intéresse à voir comment les gens
sont devenus ce qu'ils sont travaille
bien et alors vous voyez amphitryon avec
hélène perdriel robert riches quand on
voit ça à l'âge de 7 ans sa marque sa
marque pour toujours avez vous appris
votre boulot chez tania balachova et
maréchal évidemment et au cinéma aussi
ça arrive assez tardivement la
reconnaissance non oui si tu en fais
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit pour être tout à
fait sincère véritablement arrivé
aujourd'hui je ne le crois pas vraiment
avec tous les films de rennes et que
vous avez vous et oui voilà rien c'est
montrer mon grand titre de gloire je
serais très heureux de cela je pense
tout de même qu'il ya quelque chose au
cinéma qui qui me reste encore à faire
si ça se fait maintenant que ça ne se
fait pas tant pis je peux élever ma
carrière me suffit telle qu'elle est
passé utilisée au cinéma là c'est un peu
ce que vous dites là un peu et en tout
cas pas forcément comme il faudrait
m'utiliser je vais maintenant c'est une
aura là il ya d'abord celui ya des morts
celui qui n'ont pas encore été vraiment
montrés au cinéma c'est lamentable
c'est la morale et culturelle ça m'a
rendu ma piste beaucoup beaucoup du mal
là dessus
là c'est sa vision libérale de la
tellette c'est une façon de mater la
révolution
à
alors là attention vous savez qu'on va
faire une petite interview mensonge vous
êtes obligé vous qui dit toujours la
vérité
et puis c'est en liaison avec la pièce
joyeuse pâques vous êtes obligé de
mentir vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas
pendant le djing
[Musique]
vous avez cligner de l'oeil à finasser
possible c'est pas vous le dire
officiellement de boycotter ce
cérémonial stupide et injustifiée voilà
c'est ma position et je les ai je
viendrai
st
alors bien alors politiquement quel que
soit votre fidélité à vos engagements de
jeunesse
on vous a beaucoup vu ces derniers temps
en compagnie d'alain madelin et vous
avez déclaré d'ailleurs moi un type dans
le programme politique et d'enlever sa
cravate ça me va vous lui trouvez quoi
ahmad la ba hmad là je trouve qu'il a il
a un discours qui est particulièrement
adaptée à l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons et je trouve qu'il ya une
modernité est une espèce de fraternité
qui émane de ce discours qui à mon sens
devrait rassembler pratiquement toutes
les couches sociales de la nation c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je vous le voyez
très honnêtement je le vois à juste
titre d'ailleurs candidat à la
présidence de la république et j'ai la
ferme intention
et c'est parce que madelin a enlevé sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de mamie c'est
une sorte de mimétisme pour vous les
meilleurs du troisième millénaire qu'on
admirait content l'estiment quelqu'un
dont on a envie de lui ressembler c'est
un peu comme pour vous tirez vous aimez
bien vous vous êtes mis au sport fait du
vélo avec drucker
tous les dimanches matins avec michel
drucker c'est se passe comment ça se
passe pas bien pour lui parce qu'il a un
mal de chien à me suis pas entraînée ça
fait des années et des années que je
pénal mais sens du terme d'ailleurs et
lui pour le moment ils pédalent plutôt
dans la choucroute c'est à dire que il
nous est arrivé d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
très longtemps d'être filmé par ses
petits copains de la 2 et c'était très
emmerdant parce que j'étais obligé de
j'étais obligé de pédaler dans le vide
pour qu'il puisse me rattrape at il tort
beaucoup il dort énormément il
s'économise énormément
je sais pas il ya quelques jours et
quelques jurons mais peut-être que
finalement là alors il est beaucoup plus
âgée que moi à drucker et donc c'est là
où au fond c'est là la différence pour
le téléthon avait fait 5 fois le tour du
périphérique en vélo vite peut-être me
ravit x 8 x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46 secondes
quatre dixièmes alors l'une des raisons
de votre forme aussi pierre arditi c'est
que vous avez laissé tomber la drogue
d'une façon à peu près complète sauf les
pétards mais enfin bon
vous avez une dizaine de pétards par
jour parce que ça remplace cigarette on
faisait arrêter des cigarettes dont vous
êtes obligé de fumer des pétards à la
spad pas disent tout de même un pas
différent vie déjà bien un parseur du
périphérique voilà et vous avez retrouvé
votre légendaire énergie sexuelle qui a
fait votre succès faut bien le dire
parce que bien d'autres talents pierre
mais ya pas que ça non plus alors b
d'ailleurs grâce à dieu y avait cette
énergie sexuelle sinon je serais
absolument pas là où je suis aujourd'hui
voilà que pierre a retrouvé en arrêtant
la drogue son énergie sexuelle on vous a
beaucoup vu cet été avec linda hardy à
saint tropez
oui mais il y avait d'autres copines de
yahvé voir morts il y avait nagui avec
une blonde décolorée arthur avec les
maisons décorées et pierre arditi avec
une décolorés brûlé rares défis qui a
démarré on sent l'amour à mary bale donc
c'est vraiment cool à son honneur quelle
durée c'est parce qu'il va jouer si vous
voulez au gymnase marie bell s'il y
tient alors oui mais ribéry mark bell il
pas qu'on a c'est la petite oui mais la
durée de l'allaitement la mary bale on
l'applaudît
c'est joli gaston il a un autre
dinosaure il s'appelle mary bale voilà
les cantons enfant va grandir et qui va
tenir papa ya pas assez de pub sur le
plateau dieu tu vas faire quoi
concrètement je vais faire revenir
donc oui retournez-les en ce moment avec
joyeuses pâques en province il paraît
que c'est surtout de la tournée des
boîtes échangistes
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça fait
quand même une bonne dizaine d'années
que un peu plus même douzaine d'années
que mr barbier m'avait dit que au fond
sa clientèle son public on ne fabrique
qu'en province
et j'ai suivi ce conseil à la lettre
c'est d'ailleurs blier lui-même qui
m'avait dit que je pouvais justement en
profiter voilà l'avantagé des tournées
c'est sa fille voilà et donc ça fait une
bonne douzaine d'années maintenant que
je fais plus connaître le nom de boîte
échangiste vous donnerai des agresseurs
et ça sera sûrement la faire connaître
j'ai l'intention d'éditer un guide peut
dire le trio il ya le nord du guatemala
city des boîtes échangistes le arditi
avec 1h heard it is the hardy qui vous a
choqué beaucoup de monde quand même avec
votre mercedes vitres fumées sur la roue
et vous fait allumer des cigarettes par
les assistants vous trouvez pas que
c'est un peu too much pas douter vous
savez moi je vais vous dire quand on a
réussi après tout c'est un canton a du
pognon
quand on a du vent et on sait bien dans
éclaboussé maison qu'à se démerder pour
faire la même chose voilà
ont reconnu on reconnaît vraiment le may
be missed le choc
le libéral le libéral de choc alors ben
on va terminer avec la littérature fait
des lectures publiques aussi dans les
villes où vous vous allez utiliser du
renaud camus vous lisez du robert
brasillach du nietzsche oui bah c'était
gelé je n'ai découvert sur le tard et je
dois dire que j'ai eu tort
ouais c'est un manque de culture de ma
pas très bon et celui là encore il ya
une parole importante à proférer
aujourd'hui il ya une pensée que qu'on
ne partage pas suffisamment et en
particulier dans les couches basses de
la société qui vers l'iss pas comme tout
le monde le sait et je voudrais être le
le chant profond de cette parole vous la
tendance à atteindre et je ne vois pas
pour mais elle voulait de lecture de
brasillach sont remarquables et voilà
oui l'antisémitisme ça vous choque plus
du tout un fût un temps où ça vous
énervez maintenant vous vivez avec bah
qu'est ce que vous voulez non seulement
c'est dans l'air du temps alors après
tout pourquoi pas hein voilà bien dit si
merci
[Applaudissements]
bien embêté bonsoir bonsoir alors avec
laurent baffie et vous ce soir on a les
deux plus gros succès de la scène
parisienne en ce moment sacha d'affi
donc commandé un peignoir sur mesure
prochaine il ya en peignoir a très bien
il dépend tout voilà donc vous ces
joyeuses pâques de jean poiret mis en
scène par bernard murat avec caroline
sihol barbara schulz monique tarbès vous
et le théâtre c'est le théâtre des
variétés boulevard montmartre exactement
le même boulevard qu que laurent un an
la pièce a été créée en 1980 par jean
poiret a j'oubliai un truc attention
c'est prêt vous n'échapperez à rien
alors c'est une pièce sur l'adultère en
fait mais y'a pas d'adultère dans la
pièce et manon toujours comme toujours
chez poiret où j'ai fait monsieur est
pris en flagrant délit d'intention
seulement de mauvais là la tension
je fais le pitch oui fait le pitch alors
vous séduisez barbara schulz vous
l'inviter à prendre un dernier verre à
la maison et à ce moment là votre épouse
caroline silhol qui soi-disant absente
pour le week-end de pâques
elle revient elle revient à cause d'une
grève des aiguilleurs
elle revient il à sa part dans un délire
absolu
vous inventez au quart de tour à
mensonges et puis un mensonge en amène
un autre et ça se termine dans un délire
absolu intégral absolue et mis en scène
la folie de poiret quoi la vareuse
histoire folie sur l discussion lui de
plus en plus fous alors quand vous avez
vu la pièce la première fois ce monde la
création détient accompagnée par claude
rich frais et sur le trottoir en sortant
vous étiez mort de rire tous les deux et
vous avez dit j'aimerais bien jouer
cette pièce je lui dis je la jouerai
ouais je les jouais et vous l'avez
souvent un temps après ouais c'est très
jubilatoire de jouer ce personnage non
ce formidable parce qu'on peut on peut
se vautrer dans tout ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de faire dans la vie c'est bien
qu'on peut aller se vautrer dans la
lâcheté dans la mauvaise foi sont je
suis là c'est le mensonge élevé au rang
d'art suprême coincer le van gogh du
manceau
main c'est un rôle pour vous hein c'est
pas mal oui j'ai des bons souvenirs de
mon saut alors ça se passe très bien
donc c'est bourré se passe très bien
c'est pas le cas malheureusement de tous
les théâtres contenu massa quand j'ai
commencé très difficile c'est un peu
difficile il faut se dépêcher en plus
parce que c'est seulement jusqu'au 31
décembre et ce à quoi qu'il arrive c'est
fini après y'a pas de tourner il faut
bien dire aux gens les fait avant mais l
effet elle a été faite un nom après
c'est la reprise de l'école des femmes
de molière que j'ai créée à avignon cet
été
ah ouais mais ça nous donnera l'occasion
de vos invités alors mais avec messi
encore quelques petits trucs de votre
enfant ce qu'on n'a pas bien c'est vrai
indépendante choses-là l'arrêt mais bon
bah écoutez d'accord et voilà donc je
vous conseille moi je les ai vu la pièce
c'est vrai je mens bien c'est ce qu'on
peut dire du boulevard sous acide ins et
re-non sein c'est très surréaliste un
petit peu oui oui c'est formidable très
inspiré le var je veux bien qu'on
appelle ça du boulevard mais si tu est
vraiment élevé au rang d'art sur et du
boulevard comme feydeau du boulevard
jeunesse pâques
[Musique]
on va parler de choses un petit peu plus
sérieuse oui dans son article du point
la semaine dernière bernard henri lévy
rapporté une discussion qu'il avait eu
avec des amis new-yorkais pour savoir ce
qu'il faudrait faire à l'emplacement du
world trade center enfin des tours
jumelles d'un accord il est lisse
compare le théâtre qui va total des deux
ânes à partir de 9 ans on peut le
signaler parce qu'ils arrêtent table
fois de plus c'est l'avantagé de la
vedette y ait quelques accords
lamentable ma femme qui me pour ma
première très gentil maïs est lamentable
alors donc bernard henri lévy dans sa
dernière chronique du point rapporté une
discussion qu'il avait eu avec des amis
new-yorkais pour savoir ce qu'il
faudrait faire à l'endroit où étaient
les tours jumelles du world trade center
est-ce qu'il faut laisser le lieu vide
est ce qu'il fait mais c'est une ruine
comme ya un sarajevo la bibliothèque
incendiée de sarajevo hiroshima
il ya deux écoles peut-être faut-il
laisser une trace de quelque chose ne
s'est pas un morceau de ferraille qui
serait symboliserait c'est des choses
qui a eu lieu qui est terrible je crois
surtout qu'il faut qu'il faut
reconstruire la vie là dessus et je
crois que là n'est pas partisan d'un
parent d'un musée d'un mémorial vous
pensez que c'est mieux de reconstruire
quelque chose qui t'a avec fois que le
malheureusement la fin malheureusement
ou heureusement le mémorial de musées
idée dans la tête de chacun d'entre nous
je crois qu'on peut on n'oubliera jamais
cette image là donc est ce que bon ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut oublier il
n'est pas question d'oublier
je me demande si quand même la meilleure
arme contre ce terrorisme qui le
terrorisme ça veut aussi dire terreur
est-ce que ce que la terreur serait de
supprimer nos vies et la manière dont
nous vivons
peut-être faudrait-il au contraire faire
reconnaître la vie d'une manière encore
plus puissante mais peut-être la vie vit
pas forcément le symbole de l'économie
ou du fric
quelque chose d'autre oui peut-être
c'est ça qu'il faut faire non moi je
pense
c'est bien un parent passait bien pour
les les gens qui veulent rapidement
reconstruire les tours à l'identique on
peut peut-être le femmes en sous sol
pour des raisons de sécurité alors
pierre arditi vous réagissez comme ans à
cette idée qui se développe en france
depuis quelques temps qui consiste à
dire que bon ce qui s'est passé il ya un
mois cette semaine c'est bien entendu
d'effroyables mais que l'embargo
américain finalement sur l'irak a déjà
fait des centaines de milliers de morts
que ce sont eux les américains qui ont
inventé ben laden pour virer les les
russes d'afghanistan qu'ils ont défendu
israël au mépris des droits de l'homme
souvent au delà et de la justice est ce
que pour vous cette attitude qui se
développe en france actuellement le site
une attitude raisonnable ou munich oise
c'est vrai que l'amérique armes et les
talibans pour [ __ ] sur la gueule des
russes c'est clair maintenant les
talibans on se retourne contre eux qu'on
le veuille ou non
quoiqu'il pu faire les américains c'est
tout de même cette image n'est pas
acceptable je veux dire que cette cet
acte là je suis absolument désolé je
peux pas je peux pas l'accepter même si
je peux comprendre qu'un certain nombre
de choses ne sont pas résolus dans le
monde et qu'une partie de ces choses
sont de la responsabilité aussi de
l'amérique mais pas seulement
mais pas seulement il ya aussi les
responsabilités deux principaux
protagonistes est aussi responsabilité
d'un certain nombre d'états qui sont des
états confessionnels comme israël et
jacques nous avons nous la chance de
vivre dans un état dans une république
démocratique laïque et on a fait la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
c'est extrêmement différents je ne
dirais pas comme monsieur berlusconi qui
n'aura pas qu'il la rate pas une équipe
vraiment les aligne les unes derrière
les autres les conneries que nous
serions forcément supérieur nous aux
autres bien sûr que nous nous sommes
simplement différent alors cette
différence de nous permettre d'accepter
la différence de l'autre sauf si l'autre
emploie des moyens qui n'accepte plus
notre propre différence la démocratie ne
peut tolérer que ce qui la tolèrent et
là on a largement franchi les bornes
alors
non rien ne peut excuser ce qui s'est
passé à new york le 11 septembre rien
même si toute une série de choses
restent à régler nous sommes bien
d'accord là dessus je suis moi par
exemple je suis juif je ne supporterais
pas compte qu'on liquide l'état d'israël
mais je ne supporte pas non plus l'état
de délabrement de dénuement et d'errance
dans laquelle se trouve aujourd'hui le
peuple palestinien voilà
qui gère tout jeune allemand l'idée que
pensez vous de cette idée de larguer en
même temps sur l'afghanistan des bombes
pour tuer les talibans et des vivres
pour nourrir les autres vous voulez mais
ce que j'en ai dans ce même de leur
bague on était au summum de là on est au
summum delà du ridicule si on peut
employer un mot aussi dérisoire pour
quelque chose d'aussi tragiques à la
fois en balance des bombes sur des
choses qui font probablement je le dis
très honnêtement détruits moi j'ai vu un
reportage ya pas très longtemps sur m6
sur les talibans et sur ce que font les
talibans en afghanistan
c'est proprement indéfendable on ne
parle pas que des femmes d'ailleurs
quand les gens passent dans les stades
avec des fouets pour interdire aux
spectateurs de rire de sourire et qu'on
arrête le match pour exécuter des gens
sur la pelouse lieu de jouer au football
mais on peut honnêtement on peut blaguer
défendre ça c'est indéfendable
alors en même temps bien sûr qu'il faut
détruire ça peut-être aujourd'hui on en
est avec des bombes
il faudrait peut-être s'arranger pour le
détruire par d'autres moyens en même
temps à l'avenir je ne sais pas je
balance est une bombe à droite et puis
un collège littérale gauche et on sait
pas quoi dire quand on est quand même
dans un
c'est la première fois où il ya un petit
souci d'humanité pendant un bombardement
aussi donc ça va aussi un côté positif
même si l'image de monde change les
bombardements de l'irak n'a pas eu
toutes ces questions chez toi on aurait
peut-être pu balancer des unes des colis
de vivres humanitaires un peu avant de
balancer des bombes
c'est à dire il ya quelques mois ou
quelques années on n'est pas obligé
d'attendre la dénonciation comme est là
pour aider des peuples qui n'ont rien on
peut faire ça avant
[Applaudissements]
on a beaucoup parlé ici de la taxe la
taxe tobin qui consiste à prélever un
petit pourcentage sur les flux
monétaires internationaux personne
évidemment a voulu féret taxe tobin même
l'inventeur tobin ne veut plus en
entendre parler
finalement faute de payer la taxe tobin
l'occident va peut-être être obligé de
payer la taxe ben laden d'une certaine
façon ce sera plus cher oui c'est très
étonnant cette histoire de taxe tobin
d'heure parce qu'évidemment bon le
raisonnement immédiate convient pas
évidement un succès sur ses énormes
masses d'argent on prend une toute
petite partie 0,00 je sais pas quoi et
puis on aide le monde à vivre moins mal
ça semble l'évidence même bien il ya une
levée de boucliers bouclier contre ça
qui est absolument consternante alors
peut-être c'est pas le bon moyen moi je
n'ai rien je suis pas un économiste mais
on se dit quand même que ses propres
prenons une toute petite part c'est
uniquement
oui c'est même son gardien non c'est
même pas de l'argent qui appartient à
quelqu'un c'est que c'est que dalle
voilà il ya même ça s'ils sont pas
physiques visiblement un impensable à
bouger c'est un peu désespérant quand
même un progrès puisque on parle
beaucoup de ces valeurs occidentales
sa part est il supérieur aux autres et
bien peut-être faudrait-il se poser un
certain nombre de questions sur ses
valeurs et en tout cas si l'on se posait
des questions sur ses valeurs au moins
sur leur respect et sur leur sens et
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on perd un peu
la notion du sens et du fonds pour de la
forme et pour du bruit du bruit de la
fureur qui ne signifie rien comme disait
shakespeare ce bruit cette fureur me
font peur quand vous êtes plutôt un mec
simple sympa etc
on va vous faire une interview de stars
[Musique]
moi
on embauchera le moral revient le bain
fils rêve la tête
donc c'est l'interview alain delon donc
c'est vraiment cette amende lamentable
c'est lamentable
c'est misérable alors oui le début de
chaque au début de chaque réponse oui
vous devez dire pierre arditi pense que
bien un oui d'accord bakassi je
comprends alors légaliser les drogues
douces vous trouvé l'idée stupéfiante où
vous trouvez stupéfiants qu'on n'est pas
encore fait il y avait un litige
il pense que c'est plutôt stupéfiants
qu'on n'ait pas au moins essayer de le
faire voilà votre conception du luxe
c'est boire du coca dans un verre en
cristal ou du petrus dans un gobelet en
plastique rabat alors écoutez ça va être
ma main non non non
pierre arditi compte que le luxe suprême
serait tout de même de boire du petrus
et pas dans un dans une coupe en cristal
mais dans un wagon dans lequel on peut
faire tourner ce vin pour en sortir tous
les arômes à ce que le petrus et un ban
meerab voilà ce qu'il pense pierre hardy
[Applaudissements]
pour taper la frime vous préféré rouler
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
dix bornes en tracteur avec un canon il
préfère rouler 10 bornes en tracteur
avec un canon mais qui vers arditi pour
vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro pour
pierre arditi c'est évidemment
l'interdiction des mariages homos qui
nous choque le plus bien entendu bien
voilà on faire du social vous pensez
qu'il faut augmenter les salaires ou
diminuer le temps de travail
pierre arditi très emmerder mais il
arriva il va répondre
il va répondre je ne peux pas répondre
aussi crûment jeu même pierre arditi
dans même gheerardyn peut pas bien a dit
et pense qu' il n'est pas forcément
obligatoire de réduire le temps de
travail pirates qui pense qu'il serait
bon de d'augmenter certains salaires
parce que ça fait repartir l'économie
que ça permet aux gens de vivre moins
mal il ya personne qui pense qu'il peut
être un moyen terme à trouver entre une
durée du temps de travail qui serait pas
codifié à coups de serpe bien la vie ne
peut pas codifié à coups de serpe et le
travail c est aussi d'avis mais pierre
arditi pense qu'effectivement surtout
pour des gens qui gagnent peu leur vie
c'est qu'il voit assez souvent
même au cours de la sienne de vie de
pierre arditi bon j'ai quand même qu'il
serait mieux que les gens qui gagnent
peu d'argent on gagne un peu plus
allemand ferait pas de mal
voilà ce que pense pirates ça tombe bien
il est chaud il adore dire son nom
jouissant alors on va parler du commerce
du sexe
n vous pour la réouverture des maisons
closes ou pour la fermeture des boîtes à
partouzes pierre arditi 40 dans la merde
qui franchement la pierre arditi les
pour
ont beaucoup je suis pour la je suis
pour la réouverture des boîtes et
partout n'importe quoi pardon maman dit
imaginaire qu'il faut s'excuser il le
fait tous les soirs danger de 8 ha qui
va le trouver pour garder celle que vous
aimez
est-ce que vous préféreriez l'enfermer
dans un palais où là sortiront les clubs
échangistes je serais capable de faire
le pire a dit qu'ils seraient capables
de faire les deux pour garder celle
qu'il aime parce qu'il a vraiment aucune
envie de la perdre et donc il pourrait
l'enfermer dans un palais si elle le
voulait bien où la trimballer dans un
club échangiste si c'était le seul moyen
de la garder pour le club échangiste il
le ferait s'il y avait pas d'autres
moyens
il est d'accord chérie
mais c'est bien didier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
olivier
ça va pas mal j'ai un vidéo sampler s'il
fallait quelque chose qui vous plaît pas
voilà ce que je passerai c est
lamentable c'est la mode donc ça vous
évitera de répéter comme ça plusieurs
fois pendant l'émission joffrin claque
quand je pense qu'il faut le passer
si vous êtes vraiment bon je ferai ça
mais ça certes c'est un moment de débat
alors regardez dit vous êtes considéré
comme le séducteur du cinéma français
l'homme dont on est déjà passé tout de
suite le machin allez-y l'homme dont
rêvent toutes les femmes bien dit oui et
c'est vrai qu'à part vous qui est le
séducteur du cinéma français je pensais
à ça en préparant cette interview je me
dis à papa arditi et moi aussi je me le
demandait je ne voyais vraiment pas
qu'ils pouvaient tenir banon classée
vous faites bien de le dire mais je
tiens à le préciser oui à part vous qui
a votre physique avant la personne
j'espère à part vous pierre qui peut
jouer en attendant godot de beckett et
joyeuses pâques de poiret il y en a il y
en a mais non pas décimer chine y en a
j'ai un truc parce que je suis en train
de faire
j'ai loupé un truc r il s'en servira
plus que moi alors à part vous c'est con
à part vous qui faut-il aller voir au
théâtre en ce moment il ya des tas de
choses je vois je vais vous dire je vous
dis fallait avoir une très belle pièce
qui s'appelle la preuve
ouais que avec anouk grinberg avec anouk
grinberg commun heureusement maintenant
je crois qu'à nous grimbert va être
remplacé mais c'est pas grave
la pièce est magnifique elle était
formidable d'ailleurs et tout le monde
et c'est michel aumont qui va remplacer
rufus avec pas mal non plus très belle
place alors dites-moi pierre à part vous
qui pourrait remplacer christian clavier
dans astérix 3 pas grand monde
je vois pas normal en plus ça
honnêtement la joie rendez compte à quel
point vous êtes unique à part vous qui a
eu le privilège d'être second rôle
derrière bernard tapie voulez-vous me
repasser oui
le fantasme de catherine barma vous la
bonne réponse
bon c'est la godasse si vous allons-y
voilà très bien plus sérieusement à part
vous qui est l affiche de une leçon de
savoir-vivre de jean claude grumberg au
théâtre du rond-point à 18h30 jusqu'au
18 janvier perd sa personne
il serait intéressant en plus un
monologue donc vous êtes seul en scène
et voilà alors ça pouvait être que vous
la non ç'aurait pu être d'état notre
jean enfin il se trouve que jean claude
grumberg m'a demandé à moi de dire ce
texte et j'ai accepté avec plaisir et
intérêt dans un texte qui est écrit par
grimbert à partir des conseils donnés
par des médecins sous l'occupation pour
apprendre aux gens à dire du mal des
juifs en toute impunité c'est ça
l'histoire l'histoire c'est à partir de
ces textes qui ont été écrits en
particulier en 1940 par un docteur qui
s'appelait le docteur montandon et qui a
établi toute une théorie de signes
distinctifs pour bien reconnaître et
identifier le juif c'est à dire les
juifs textes qui sont absolument
impensable dont on n'ose pas imaginer le
contenu que ce que je vais dire
d'ailleurs
effectivement de ces textes sont nés les
doigts les lois anti juives de
l'occupation alors grimbert avec sa
causticité naturelle lui à transformer
ça en une leçon savoir vivre et le
chapitre traité c'est la fin de repas
c'était de faire repasser 3 c'est
difficile ça peut tout se passe bien
puis tout d'un coup un mot déplacé une
attitude qui peut être irrévérencieuse
et ça vous fout le repas en l'air voilà
et pourquoi ça vous fout le repas en
l'air parce que bon au début du repas
pour mettre de l'ambiance
vous aviez vous aviez
effet une petite plaisanterie sur les
[ __ ] alors bon ça n'avait pas
déclenché l'hilarité générale
j'ai senti que les gens ne suis pas
totalement hostile qui au milieu du
repas vous y êtes allé sur votre que sur
votre couplet sur les [ __ ] là non
plus
bon vous a pas taper dessus mais j'avais
bien senti que les gens ne te pas
malveillant votre égard et donc tout
naturellement en fin de repas vous en
venez tout naturellement à dire avoir ce
besoin bien légitime de dire du mal des
juifs et à ce moment là le mec qui est
en face de vous vous balance son verre
de mouton rothschild 87 à la gueule
parce qu'il l'est qu'il ne supporte pas
que et que et à partir de cette manière
de tourner en dérision quelque chose qui
est absolument immonde grimbert retombe
sur ces fameux texte et lui tourne ça sa
manière c'est écoutez si vous voulez
pouvoir continuer de dire du mal des
juifs en public en toute impunité
assurez vous d'abord que vous n'êtes pas
en face d'un juif donc le seul moyen de
le savoir
ces deux qu'on vous donne les points
d'europe de repérage pour être
absolument certains que vous êtes en
face de quelqu'un qui ne l'est pas voilà
après évidemment on tombe sur l'infamie
la plus totale qui n'est pas excusable
d'ailleurs quand il s'agit de juifs que
quand il s'agit bien sûr de [ __ ] comme
on le dit ou d'arabes
comme on dit c'est toujours la même
chose c'est à dire c'est la haine de
l'autre
quoi voilà donc ça s'appelle une leçon
de savoir vivre
c'est au théâtre du rond point tous les
soirs à 18h30
là j'ai une question la question de
lionel jospin
[Musique]
pierre arditi
oui si ces représentations sont un échec
est-ce que vous assumerait pleinement la
responsabilité de cet échec
est-ce que vous en tirez les conclusions
en vous retirant de la vie théâtrale
après le 18 janvier voulez-vous me
passer pour le petit
je savais que ça servirait je savais ça
vous évite de le faire oui avouez quand
même que c'est facile alors vous avez
des souvenirs de lecture parce que quand
vous étiez enfant votre tante vous lisez
des livres à voix haute pierre arditi
parce que vous n'arriviez pas à vous
endormir vous aviez le sentiment que si
vous vous endormez ben vous vous
réveillerez jamais quoi c'était comme
mourir pour vous sans dormir
c'est surtout parce que j'avais le
sentiment qu'on me ce qu'on me prive est
vie ouais c'est dire que comme mes yeux
devaient se faire mais je voyais plus de
monde et puis au bout d'un moment
contraint forcé par ma grand mère par ma
mère par toute la famille de dormir à
une heure où personne ne dort c'est
absolument déraisonnable de faire dormir
quelqu'un dans la journée même en france
tant de pire que tout alors j'ai fini
par la force de ma de mon énergie et de
mon refus de fermer les yeux de les
fermer tout de même j'ai découvert que
j'entendais tout de même le bruit de la
vie à cette époque là on habitait place
wagram sur la place et alors il y avait
le boulevard pereire et puis la place et
puis il y avait la petite ceinture qui
passait le long de l'immeuble
et puis les autobus avec cette
merveilleuse chasse qui ressemblait aux
chasseurs c'est vrai dans les abris
formidable quand vous aurez de la petite
machine du poinçonneur qui oblitère elle
toute sa secte j'entendais tout ça est
un moment donné je me suis mais c'est
magnifique au fond je peux fermer les
yeux c'est encore plus beau quand je les
ai ouvert parce que là je peux repeindre
le monde comme j'en ai envie
imaginez la couleur de l'autobus ch
pourrait imaginer ça marche je peux
imaginer que les vitesses grince parce
qu'une voiture qui l'empêchent de passer
et j'ai rock refabriquer reconstituer le
monde avec mon imaginaire en fermant les
yeux et je ce livre que je dis ce que je
dis toujours que je finirais pas écrire
que commencer d'ailleurs commence comme
ça par se souvenir de la vire créer tes
yeux fermés qui s'appelle le sommeil où
l'on ne meurt pas très bien ici
[Applaudissements]
le temps humide et ont surtout c'est
seulement du temps oui bien sûr bien sûr
alors là on a parlé de théâtre bientôt
on va voir dans un film qui s'appelle le
mystère de la chambre jaune avec denis
podalydès est un film de bruno podalydès
avec sabine azéma alors après il y aura
un film d'alain resnais d'après une
opérette de maurice yvain qui s'appelle
pas sur la bouche
toujours avec sabine azéma oui alors la
télé vous faites toujours le personnage
récurrent de sauveur giordano sur tf1
ils n'ont pas de problème avec vous tf1
quand vous parlez de la télé parce que
vous êtes drôlement violon j'ai encore
entendu l'autre jour sur france inter ça
les embête pas tf1
non il ya des choses que fait tf1 que je
n'aime pas et je ne défends pas et il ya
des choses que le service public ne fait
pas et que ça m'emmerde qu'ils ne le
fassent pas voilà alors je vous
conseille une émission lundi
lundi soir à 20h50 sur france 2 en prime
time
ça s'appelle tribu mesdames messieurs
l'animateur est magnifique type génial
alors pierre arditi oui et thierry
ardisson oui
pourquoi cueillir la guerre la guerre
quoi avec l'irak
on se pense pas quand même que la france
ait envie de jouer les va-t-en-guerre
d'ailleurs personne n'en a envie
même les anglais qui étaient très très
un vêtement derrière l'amérique ont
l'air de temporiser parce que il ya
comme vous le savez sans doute en
regardant le journal de votre chaîne qui
est excellent et bien le rapport
intermédiaire ou le premier rapport
inspecteurs dit bien que pour le moment
il n'y a aucune trace des fameuses armes
de destruction massive
donc on peut tout de même pas aller
casser la tronche à un pays 18 millions
d'habitants dont une bonne partie de ses
18 millions sont exempts gay à l'autre
de l'agonie le final on peut penser
quand même que ce pays là n'a pas grands
moyens d'inquiéter la plus grande
puissance du monde alors qu'on prenne
des précautions bien sûr qu'on allait
voir sur place très bien enfin bon
j'arrête la guerre c'est pas vous croyez
sérieusement que les américains ils ont
envoyé 100 mille ji yai j'ai lancé lundi
à amiens comme ça ils ont fait tout ça
pour les enlever non ils n'ont sûrement
pas fait tout ça pour les enlever mais
écoutez moi je suis pas un pacifiste je
suis un pacifique
voilà alors tant qu'il n'y a pas de
preuve absolue que tout ça existe je
vois pas au nom de quoi on irait [ __ ]
sur la gueule de ce pays
je n'ai pas une passion pour le soleil
moussanais personnellement s'attaquera
matin sapée ça mais je le peuple irakien
franchement il m'a rien fait dans l'ain
il ya des gens tout à fait dignes de
respect là bas on peut pas leur taper
sur la tronche comme ça sur des
présomptions
voilà alors quand tu auras des preuves
peut-être qu'il faudra voir et de toute
façon
tout ça doit passer par si je me
souviens bien par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu le dantec
les règles soient bien respectées non
s'il me semble me souvenir que c'est ça
la donner normalement un donc on va pas
faire ça sans sa façon on a déjà la côte
d'ivoire la france elle est vraiment
honnêtement elle fait ce qu'elle peut
pour que les gens de ce centre déchire
pas non peut pas on ne peut pas vous
trouvez que le milieu des affaires
étrangères dominique de villepin a bien
agi là dessus en tout cas à côté il est
allé sur place et il a essayé de
temporiser les choses il a fait me
semble t-il tout à fait honnête rama est
correctement son travail les alors sur
l'intérieur de la france sarkozy à ce
qu'ils trouvent je savais bien qu'il
allait me la poser cette petite question
pourquoi me ben écoute qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je trouve je me trouve
je ne vous voulez que je vous dise
honnêtement le fond de ma pensée oui je
vais vous le dire
quitte à vous choquer la première des
choses à dire c'est que nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy a le sale boulot du
gouvernement voilà c'est clair comme
tous les ministres de l'intérieur il n'y
a pas de ministre de l'intérieur qui ait
jamais été populaire c'est le premier
flic du pays
c'est pas marrant c'est difficile
particulièrement en ce moment
c'est vrai qu'il ya des menaces
terroristes un peu partout donc c'est
pas absolument génial c'est vrai qu'ils
s'attaquent un certain nombre de choses
avec lesquelles très honnêtement je vous
le dit personnellement je suis d'accord
je veux dire que le le
l'insécurité routière je suis totalement
épais mais fondamentalement ou une
voiture c'est pas une arme
voilà quand torres c'est très délicat
c'est à manipuler avec des pincettes
il ya des choses contre lesquelles il
faut lutter on parle d'une manière
générale de l'insécurité
moi je préfèrerais parler d insécurité
il ya une insécurité effectivement qui
est bon qu'ils existent il existe deux
manières un peu plus aiguë aujourd'hui
parce que la société est probablement
plus dur il faut faire très attention
avec ce qu'on manipule qui qui qui on
emmerde qui on emmerde pas à savoir que
très souvent mois pour l'avoir vers
pression j'ai rencontré des ptic des
petits gars d'idées cité en question un
peu comme ça un peu machin comme ça et
puis on discutait trois minutes avec eux
et puis quand on peut prendre le temps
de discuter quand on quand ils
s'intéressent à vous intéresser à eux
vous apercevez que ce sont des gosses
comme tout le monde et que simplement
peut-être il faut il faut peut-être
faire qu'on leur rappelle ou qu'on les
aide à retourner à l'école où il prendre
un intérêt à cette école de la
république qui fera qu'à un moment donné
ils pourront devenir des hommes de
demain ceux qui ne peuvent pas toujours
faire dans le tas ya toujours des noyaux
de 2,2 d'emmerdeur ou de [ __ ] ou de
petits truands mais ils sont c'est une
c'est une poignée c'est rien c'est une
tête d'épinglé par rapport à la grande
majorité des gosses qu'on peut je ne
peux pas croire que ces gosses t'assois
perdu je ne veux pas le croire
voilà donc sarkozy trapé pas la maman
personnellement je ne ne peux pas en
dire du mal et lionel vous l'avez oublié
je n'ai pas changé de bord ma famille ma
sensibilité est toujours celle là
maintenant je n'ai pas oublié jeu
je pense que c'est lui qui pour le
moment se fait oublier sans doute parce
qu'il en a besoin et sans doute parce
que je crois que quand il a dit qu'il y
renonçait à la vie politique je crois
qu'il était sincère qui est pas un effet
de manche c'est un type très droit à
lionel jospin regard venir non ah non on
pensait par non je pense pas non un bon
nom très bien est ce que vous avez pris
des bonnes résolutions pour 2003 clair
aucune à bon vous savez pas décidé
d'arrêter de fumer par
puis j'arrête de décider si je décide
d'arrêter de fumer tous les jours pour
garçons je mange des pastilles et puis
hein je m arrête un changement est tous
là alors j'en suis au pastis et je filme
dix fois moins qu'avant mais enfin bon
ils devraient être temps d'arrêter
comme vous pouvez le constater je ne
touche non mais vous savez pourquoi vous
avez repris vous avez pas voulu prendre
un patch et vous êtes cru très fort vous
ai dit je peux m'arrêter de filmer sans
pattes je les fais un an
essayez le pat je vais essayer le patch
dirige promettez moi mais vous avez d
intérêt pour le patch pour vos pierres
mais je comprends bien
non mais je sais que vous m'aimez bien
beaucoup c'est vrai alors la pièce donc
s'appelle une leçon de savoir vivre
c'est au théâtre du rond-point à 18h30
tous les soirs jusqu'au 18 janvier voilà
donc le monologue s'appelle une leçon de
savoir vivre donc je vais vous faire une
interview une leçon de savoir vivre
[Musique]
alors car dit-il
vraiment vous savez vivre vous est ce
que le papa est ce qu'il vaut mieux
suivre une dame qui monte un escalier
pour éviter qu'elles ne tombent
évidemment en arrière où l'a précédé
pour pas regarder ses fesses
c'est lamentable
celle là vous savez qu'il faut il faut
la suivre
quitte à regarder ses fesses oui mais ça
veut dire qu'on sait qu'elle va tomber
alors ça veut dire que voilà oui bon
enfin c'est ça bon alors au cinéma oui
vaut-il mieux essayer d'ouvrir lentement
un bonbon ou bien y aller d'un coup sec
pour que ça fasse le moins de bruit
possible et bien au cinéma c'est très
simple il faut pas manger de bonbons
parce qu'on est pas au restaurant les
jours raconte l'histoire c'est l'anglais
un jour alain resnais tête au cinéma est
il allé voir un film je pas lequel est
devant lui avec deux dames qui parlait
alors elle parle elle parle elle parlait
puis abandonné la lumière baisse
et puis la lumière s'éteint qu'il rideau
s'ouvre et puis le générique commence
elle continue elle continue à parler
alors à l'aréna qui est très poli ne dit
rien et puis un moment donné la première
image du film apparaît il ya deux
acteurs qui se regardent ils les bonnes
femmes continuent de parler alors un
moment donné très poliment il redit
mesdames et mesdames
est-ce que vous pouvez vous taire parce
que le film est commencée et à ce moment
là il ya une des deux âmes qui s'est
retournée équidés vers l'année qui lui
et qui lui a dit mais monsieur ils ne
disent rien
[Applaudissements]
alors siens leçons de savoir-vivre
vaut-il mieux insulté un postier qui
vous fait attendre où une employée de la
sécu qui vous a oublié font insulter
personne franchement dans un bus
vaut-il mieux laisser sa place à une
jeune femme enceinte moche ou à une
vieille dame séduisante
écoutez comme n'y a qu'une seule place
il faut le céder à l'une des deux
pointes à la voile à petit le mieux
montrer sa déception de ne pas avoir eu
de molière ou de ne pas avoir eu de
césar faut montrer aucune déception
parce que je suis bien placé pour en
parler en ayant eu quelques-uns les
molières les césar c'est absolument
délicieux c'est comme une bonne critique
ça fait du bien comme ça quand on se
retourne sur son passé en dix ans une
certaine époque les gens de mon métier
mon reconnu mais d'une certaine manière
ils peuvent vous reconnaître aussi sans
césar et sans mollir mode il mieux
savoir mort et au savoir vivre faut
savoir vivre savoir mourir ça sert à
rien parce que ça à temps tout le monde
et on n'apprend pas la mort la mort ça
s'apprend pas ça peut se douter ça peut
se craindre ça peut faire du mal
peu douloureux mais ça ne s'apprend pas
la vie par contre ça c'est absolument
fondamental le seul petit bruit de nous
qui restera ce sera la manière dont il
aura vécu
messieurs
je pense à un truc leur temps en temps
que vous êtes là vous allez me faire par
exemple un beau c'est lamentable comme
ça je l'aurais en stock
serge tu allais 6-1 2-3 c'est lamentable
mais c'est lamentable
elle est bien esprit me faire un c'est
formidable non c'est remarquable ce sera
plus vous ça ces remarques faites moi
assez remarquable ça j'aurai les deux
ces remarques à des vidéos sans beurre
dans l'année parce que vous n'avez pas
venir non plus toutes les semaines pour
dire ses remarques à bout c'est
lamentable avec moi je suis demandé
d'être là nous vous remercie ça vous
évite de venir pourrait faire autre
chose voilà c'est ça comme ça où je fais
potiche même quand je suis pas lassé
les musiciens c'est bien dit il
[Musique]
bonsoir commence à vacquières joey starr
julie delpy gyan louvain jean jacques
debout viande outil qui arrive du
théâtre ça va oui c'est bien passé mal
ils ont applaudi à la fin pas mal à ce
serait bien ouais ça c'est bien son nom
ouais c'est que je rencontre des gens
que ma mère aurait voulu rencontrer et
je suis d'accord et l'accuse moines iowa
je suis d'accord non il est entre
copains tous les deux fait gaffe je
voulais dire à louvain pierre arditi
frégate son image non est ce que tu peux
donner une carte de bons clients à
pierre arditi parce que c'est vraiment
le bon client type vous savez pierre que
la chaîne fait des faits des études sur
les invités des émissions séries pour
rendre ça non et alors il ya une étude
qui a été faite sur les invités de
l'émission l'année dernière vous arrivé
largement en tête c'est marrant qui est
effrayant ce nom
cents et rennes car demain
la chaîne pétulant les points clés que
l'étude nous a transmis ses charme fou
sens de l'est nous eh oui avis sur tout
ah oui ça bien sûr l'invité idéal
bon voilà l'écouté pas besoin de vous
interviewer les gens sont méchants et
ses enfants de partir je vise mais les
gens sont heureux de le voir pierre
hardy qui dès 21h si on pouvait faire un
gros plan
m la seule chose qu'ils veulent c'est ce
qu'on peut voir la gueule mon cas c'est
tout oui voilà c'est même pas la peine
de parler les gens voient ça gueule son
prix voilà voilà très bien là les gens
sont heureux ça tire ça commence à 10 ou
way très bien mais déjà c'est lamentable
fait nul à ce que maintenant je ne peux
plus me trimbaler nulle part
tout le monde me dit si bien il ya un
truc quand même que les gens comprennent
pas bien
pierre c'est votre mac sans ces dossiers
c'est que les avait déclaré il ya
longtemps bien sûr mais sarkozy je suis
pas complètement contre est-ce que c'est
toujours le cas j'ai dit simplement que
à un moment donné sur certains points
très précis d'ailleurs qu'on peut
énumérer ici si vous visiter absolument
ouais je n'étais pas absolument content
quand il supprime la double peine c'est
lui qu'il fait je regrette que la gauche
ne l'ait pas fait avant lui d'accord il
serait d'accord avec moi que ça fait
bien s'imagine un quand il
se décide qu'à un moment donné les mecs
qui pensent que la puissance de leur
voiture est inversement proportionnelle
au coefficient de dilatation de l'eau ce
type est un
d'une certaine manière ça ne me choque
pas vraiment moi je on est on est un
c'est facile c'est venu mais attention
gens comme un non mais sérieux lankais
en fait vous savez vous savez bien que
sarkozy qui a fait des trucs bien
effectivement comme la suppression de la
double peine mais est ce que par exemple
quand il dit il faut des amendes pour
les pétards fumé un pétard et une amende
de 10000 balle plus confiscation du
portable + confiscation du scooter et
c'est sans doute pas la solution non
d'un sérieux vous pouvez pas le suivre
là dessus sarkozy jette en mer pays sort
du théâtre il est le suivant le premier
tri qui a fait un tabac
alors sarkozy il faut être avoir
quelqu'un qui sort de ce jeune succès je
ne suis pas forcément d'accord a dit
merci c'est quoi c'est quoi il a craché
il ya un peu de tout c'est monstrueux
savez je connais pas mais bien non mais
je n'aurais vous emmerdez simplement
qu'ils vont payer si le conflit israélo
palestinien
en trente secondes au record de merde
rapidement un nom mais la suppression
des prostituées par exemple être
d'accord et la confiscation des
portables pour les prostituées et des
auteurs à la suppression des prostituées
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut définir la
liaison avec les quartiers chics parce
que ça fait sale
non ils essayent de je pense qu'ils
essayent de de régler le problème comme
nikos et ses passagers je me demande
j'ai encore comme dira omar sharif la
prostitution c'est mon dada suppression
mais moi ce n'est pas la suisse est pas
les simples la suppression des
prostituées c'est ce n'est pas ta
volonté de réguler la prostitution ou en
tout cas de faire que que que la
prostitution qui dans certains cas peut
être assimilé à un esclavage
parce qu'un certain nombre de ces jeunes
femmes sont pas forcément d'accord avec
son leur demande de faire plus tout de
même raisonnablement se poser la
question de savoir si on ne pourrait pas
essayer de voir si on peut pas faire
autrement quand même c'est pas une
question absolument indigne 1 parce que
les moyens employés sont bons je peux
pas vraiment répondre mais en tout cas
le fait qu'on se préoccupe du problème
n'est pas en soi une tare très
honnêtement non mais oui tiens je vous
demandais si je dois pierre moi j'ai un
avantage c'est que si vous me posez
lequel après ça ça me fait rêver ce que
j'ai à dire ce que je pense que
j'arriverai vous êtes chez vous c'est
qu'au début vous défendez un peu et
après vous nous faites 7 sur 7 et
j'adore ça
[Applaudissements]
bien alors castro je ne parle pas de
castro parce que lundi c'est à dire
après demain à 20h30
vous êtes au théâtre du rond-point à
l'appel de reporters sans frontières
le lendemain toujours au théâtre du
rond-point donc et du mardi au samedi à
20h30 sur scène avec ariane ascaride
pierre arditi vous interpréter une pièce
qui s'appelle mathilde une pièce de
véronique olmi mise en scène par didier
long
c'est après trois mois de prison suite
un détournement de mineure le garçon
avait 14 ans mathilde qui joué par
ariane ascaride qui a 40 ans qui est
écrivain revient chez son mari pierre
joué par vous qui est cancérologue et
elle comprend elle comprend pas que que
le désir et le plaisir soit puni par la
justice
oui enfin pour l acte sexuel c'est
quelque chose de normal c'est quelque
chose de naturel et elle comprend pas
que ce moment était puni de deux ans de
prison
c'est à ce désir de ce jeune homme ou de
ce sept enfants en cours de fabrication
parce que simplement le désir est là et
donc elle cède à cette tentation c'est
puni par la loi ça s'appelle un
détournement de mineure elle fait trois
mois de taule et elle revient chez elle
elle vient récupérer des affaires et
dans ses affaires évidemment il ya son
mari qui s'appelle pierre qui n'est pas
allé la voir en prison
en réalité on apprend à la fin de la
pièce qu'il est venu qui n'a jamais
réussi à rentrer parce qu'ils pouvaient
pas et en fait elle vient non pas en
état de culpabilité par rapport à ce
qu'elle a vécu
mais elle vient au contraire pour
asséner cet acte là qu'elle revendique
comme quelque chose d'aigus dans sa vie
elle donne beaucoup de détails sur la
façon dont ce jeune garçon de 14 ans lui
a fait l'amour elle dit qu'elle a pris
beaucoup de plaisir qu'elle n'avait
jamais pris autant de plaisir avec un
homme week avec ce jeune garçon de 14
ans ce serait dur à jouer quand elle lui
disait lui
lui me prenait part derrière non elle ne
le dit pas c'est la mode c'est
lamentable
oui bah alors accusé et est alors lui il
a tout perdu à cause d'elles a perdu son
image la part de ses amis la police des
patients oui il mais il gagne quelque
chose d'autre un yen quoi il gagne
peut-être quelqu'un qui lui dit que la
vie mérite d'être vécue autrement et pas
seulement dans une sorte de confort
endormi d'une situation confortable où
on finit par ne plus regarder la femme
avec laquelle on vit on finit par la
prendre pour une lampe qu'on allume et
qu'on est un engrais de son de ça donne
envie
il gagne ça c'est fondamental ce qu'ils
gagnent
c'est mieux que la clientèle franchement
une grande qualité vous pierre sait si
votre ouverture au monde des femmes
c'est vrai oui je sens que vous allez
oui merci savez quoi oui je sais je sers
henry on va faire une interview
bonsoir mesdames
[Musique]
j'adore d'où vient donc pierre vous êtes
une femme oui d'accord d'accord
oui mais c'est tellement fou rire
ailleurs vous appelez comment je
m'appelle à la résille n a émis des n 10
millièmes médiane c'est joli mais ces
jeunes c'est bien ça fait moche
émilienne oui émilienne c'est joli
minois il vous plait pierre arditi par
le plus fort les à gérer quand même
[Rires]
c'est monstrueux il me donne une carte
pour revenir si bien hâte un nouveau
slogan c'est monstrueux ça va rester
assez monstrueux emiliani vous plaît
pierre arditi il ya pire hein c'est pas
parfait mais il ya pire allez vous savez
pas sérieusement oui
ne trouvez pas qu'il fait un peu vieux
beau quand même a sûrement oui en tout
cas vieux sur m'embaucher patricia aussi
beau ainsi si vieux oui émilienne oui
oui mon grand est ce que vous êtes une
femme facile non non du coup chez quoi
le troisième soir c'était une bêtise
alors qu'on peut garder celle là c'est
pathétique
est ce que tu veux dire face caméra
s'est passé pathétique de la lingerie
sil vous plait emilienne à oui vous avez
quoi comme la dga à celle là j'ai un
truc qui remonte un peu en balconnet
parce qu'évidemment tous atteints comme
vous l'avez très justement fait
remarquer je ne suis plus de 2 de la
première messe mais pas mal oui enfin
bon
vous n'avez pas envie de vous faire
refaire les seins emilienne pas trop non
en ce moment contre les rides du
merisier vous faites quoi emilienne
écouter absolument rien de temps en
temps quand même je me regarde dans là
je me dis que peut-être faudrait finir
par monter tout ça sans lever ses plis
puis au bout les enjeux lignon il ya là
le petit garçon de la jeune femme qui a
fait les magnifiques éclairages de la
pièce qui est absolument adorable qui a
deux ans et demi qui ressort d'une
maladie assez grave et qui revient à la
vie maintenant qui est venu sur le
plateau pendant qu'on répétait il était
absolument divin il a sauté sur le
plateau il a commencé à sauter et moi je
faisais attention parce que j'ai peur
qu'ils tombent alors il a rentré dahlias
et je l'aimais bien lui il a dit à sa
mère je les aime bien il a dit le
monsieur qui est un peu abîmée c'est mon
copain ça m'a beaucoup plu
c'est pour ça va bien
pour ça je voudrais pas me faire refaire
vous préférez qui me viennent sur ce
plateau
c'est un endroit on n'élimine pas donc
j'élimine situe devant virer un seul
mais c'est ce genre de question que je
vous pose est ce pas choisi gérard pour
toi je choisirais quoi toi aussi tu es
choisi le cinéma la joie c'est moi qui
convient bush à propos pour la nuit tu
choisirais dès qu'il apprend la mèche
serrée qui je suis hétéro mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les fidèles
qui comme moi aussi pierre di fiemme une
brique ça
[Musique]
et altiéri bruit voilà ce que pierre
dites vous
vous
et voilà ce qu elle une vie de pierre
ainsi tango selected un pas ou si si si
ça va pas mal c'est lamentable comme
d'habitude cet accord ces concepts qui
vise à masquer la peur à vous arrivez du
théâtre edouard vii tous les deux là bah
oui vous répétiez oui c'est le temps des
fêtes vous savez votre texte mon gros
oui ouais ça va c'est l'idée c'est en
salle et on devra aller oui et où ça va
pas mal ça se présente bien cette
histoire
alors donc la pièce que nos amis répète
en ce moment s'appelle lune de miel de
noël coward c'est un grand classique du
théâtre british on peut dire et s'est
adaptée par eric-emmanuel schmitt et
s'est mis en scène par bernard murat
donc jusque là c'est la dream team non
plus je crois qu'ils sont les vrais donc
ça ajoute à la qualité de nos nîmes dans
ce métier des gens qui usurpent le
politicien pierre arditi qu'est venu à
15 m de long dans les chiottes rentrer
un jour ce qui reste des coûts de papier
bon voilà alors comment ça va c'est
lamentable bien on va raconter un petit
peu d'histoire de la pièce fait moins
que ça au moins le pitch donc donc ça
après vous être aimé passionnément enfin
je veux dire dans le dans la pièce à
après bien sûr après vous êtes aimés
passionnément vous est divorcé il ya
cinq ans chacun a refait sa vie de son
côté et ses remarques et chacun de son
côté or pendant c'est bien l'idée
pendant la première nuit de la lune de
miel
vous découvrez l'un et l'autre que vous
êtes dans le même hôtel et vous êtes
complètement paniquée voulaient fuir
mais vos nouveaux partenaires
comprennent pas pourquoi voulez vous en
aller et voilà est donc évidemment s'en
suit une histoire rocambolesque et je
vous laisse imaginer on va pas raconter
la suite mais enfin disons que c'est un
point de départ assez intéressant on en
fait joli comme c'est joli comme il est
maintenant très bien plus ce qui est
encore mieux c'est qui non seulement ils
sont dans le même hôtel mais ils sont
dans deux appartements mitoyens qu'ils
ont conquis pratiquement comme un quand
ils sortent ils sont ici je prends le
sundgau ce qui est pratiquement le
théâtre parce qu'on peut voir les gens
de face et de moyens on voit les deux
parties ça très intéressante à jouer car
c'était foutu c'est pas con niveau de la
scénographie
c'est qu'on s'est bien marré là on est
dans un bar et se sent bien
laurent baffie qui est quand même un
dramaturge lui aussi je crois qu'on peut
le dire c'est vrai on peut le dire on
peut le dire sans en rougir un cinéaste
également également fait un film qui a
fait son succès on peut le dire
heureusement vous avez fait un petit
bout dans le film de langue parce que
sinon je peux pas ce qu'on retiendra de
vote c'est d'ailleurs ça a boosté un peu
takayama faire ça m'a fait un bien fait
retravailler un peu comme nagui là il
suçait j'étais un peu un peu dans le
bain
depuis trop
et voilà elle c'est la sortie d'affaires
beatty revenue au top il est au top là
au top au top
bon mon pierrot qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire d'autre sur la pièce et aux gens
d'y aller évidemment parce que tout ce
que j'ai dit là ça ça ne peut que donner
envie ils ont en fait un film de sa déjà
parce que c'est un scénar de film
absolument rien n'ont pas fait de films
de cette pièce de que de khobar de la
pièce d'un film lobby qui a fait un film
de design for living canada 3 qui est
une très jolie pièce c'est les deux
pièces les plus célèbres de kohat
mais la bbc a tourné avec des acteurs
prestigieux noms dans la distribution
d'origine y avait co-animé y avait aussi
laurence olivier
maintenant il est décédé c'était pas
très bonne est approuvée par des
fissures laurence olivier non c'est très
joli c'est joli hâle on dit toujours que
coward c2c de guitry anglais mais en
réalité c'est pas tout à fait sans quoi
un tri c'est très très esprit français
très brillant très filant coward sait on
est plus sur les sentiments la
psychologie humaine c'est très gracieux
j'ai très glamour en même temps c'est
peut-être plus cruel faisait vue et
devine chez michel drucker et quelques
temps oh là là oui vous attendiez il
vous a demandé quelque chose de très
grave
il vous a dit est-ce que c'est pas
difficile de jouer avec l'homme dont on
partage la vie savait qu'il fallait
penser à celle à 10 ans sur les avancées
regarde regarde de ce drame
vive la vie ne vous pouvez vous dire un
truc je voudrais pas faire une interview
trop en mer dont je vais vous épargner
non monsieur d'une bonne question plus
c'est vrai mais répondait
c'était très bien le dimanche après midi
ses amis sont bien tous vos copains qui
sont venus dire c'est que c'est
formidable
oui je t'ai mérité mais j'aimerais bien
la faire cette émission des gens qui ont
des amis mais c'est ça après ça le
problème papa collage tous tes amis tu
viens de dire que tu es génial tu crois
que moi ça marcherait pas attendre un à
tendance à préférer le 10 minutes mais
diminué alors je répète encore une fois
que tout le monde soit bien au courant
c'est le 6 février donc date historique
s'il en est
odile en voilà au théâtre edouard vii et
ça s'appelle
c'est le 7 février au théâtre et noir
citant le site
donc ce qu'on voit en tous les cas à la
lumière de cette anecdote relatée dans
la prière incroyable c'est qu'en fait
c'est un petit peu dans votre vie
quotidienne un petit peu comme au cinéma
non non on va voir on va faire une
interview dans la vraie vie
on s'entraîne on pense en fait nous
rêver aussi est ce que dans la vraie vie
il vous arrive de vous jouer la comédie
l'un à l'autre non pierre
non non jamais non non bon enfant non
non franchement bien son nom n'a pas
besoin non nous on a là on a dont là on
à la comédie et on ouvre la porte à la
maison puis boum comédie derrière donc à
la maison vous êtes comme en bas la
maison n'a pas besoin de ça on fait
autre chose
joël à la maison non non je n'ai pas de
tee shirt tu es vraiment naze
alors peut-être et une commande pour la
prochaine fois est ce que est ce que
dans la vraie vie il vous arrive
d'entendre des applaudissements dans les
moments de tendresse ou juste après oui
pourquoi il ya souvent des coups de
théâtre dans votre vie evelyne les trois
crans dans la vraie vie frappe les trois
coups
c'est ça non j'essaie de tant que faire
se peut dans leur mire la brigade
alors là c'est pas là c'est pas
lamentable athée notoire essaye de
transe de transformer la vie tant que
faire se peut en tout cas le quotidien
comme quelque chose qui est plus magique
est plus mystérieux et plus agréable et
plus rigolo tant que faire se peut alors
ça c'est important est ce que dans la
vraie vie vous fait relâche le lundi
pas du tout non est ce que dans la vraie
vie faisait déjà trouver un amant dans
le placard non non donc c'est pas du
tout du tout du tout comme au théâtre
finalement la vraie vie pas vraiment non
un entracte non est ce que dans la vraie
vie pierre il ya une scène que vous ne
vous lasserez jamais de jouer avec
evelyne il y en a plusieurs
oui j'ai dit oui il y en a au moins une
oui bien sûr la cassette sk une scène
dans la vraie vie que vous voulez plus
jamais jouer avec elle vim il ya des
scènes que je n'aimerais pas avoir à
jouer avec evelyne quoi par exemple les
scènes qu'on jouerait bien honnêtement
pour revenir avec ses passes aidant il
ya des scènes que je rejoins là il a des
souvenirs car je ne voulais je ne vous
les jeunes gens nourris
le parking l'anecdote du parking d'ordre
pierre non en dehors de la chambre ont
la loge et tout ça quand elle vous a
collé le tas d'autres endroits
kuhn accusé la buanderie tu prévu
andré-pierre ne descend pas le cheval et
où on était très voiture nous voilà
voilà voilà voilà pour la revente
devrait coûter 1 voiture on a eu de très
joli retour de tournage en voiture
[Musique]